la présidentielle et depuis le début de
la semaine nous vous interrogeons sur
les enjeux de cette campagne aujourd'hui
parole de citoyens va à la rencontre de
francis ce retraité et bénévole aux
restos du coeur à tours pour lutter
contre la pauvreté des seniors il plaide
pour un grand ministère des solidarités
romain des piles
depuis trois ans qu'il est à la retraite
francis et bénévoles aux restaurants du
coeur il est responsable de l'entrepôt
des restos ce retraité de france télécom
dit avoir une retraite confortable mais
il n'oublie pas que d'autres sont
obligés de continuer de travailler à
cause de pension trop maigre les
résidents des promesses
qu'il faut trouver un minimum pour
justement avoir une retraite correcte
pour pouvoir vivre et profiter justement
de cette retraite de toutes les choses
qu'on n'a pas pu faire en activité un
peu de voyage un peu de promenade un peu
voilà effectivement avoir un revenu
décent pour pouvoir faire profiter de sa
retraite et de les quelques années de
jeunesse qu'on peut encore avoir à
pouvoir se promenèrent pouvoir marcher
pouvoir voyager mais même vivre tout
simplement quoi au resto la distribution
de repas et de produits d'hygiène se
fait sans distinction d'âge et les
chiffres sont têtus et cruel pour la
société française de plus en plus de
jeunes et de plus en plus de retraités
sont dans le besoin pour francis ingrand
ministère des solidarités à part entière
serait nécessaire c'est le bénévolat qui
permet à des personnes de pouvoir se
nourrir s'habiller se nettoyer se laver
alors que c'est un minimum que chaque
personne chaque être humain devrait
avoir tous les jours voilà alors quelle
est la solution
ce qui a un ministère a créé est ce que
il
mystère de ses proches des jeunes des
retraités ans si ce n'est pas très
confiant à l'avenir et comme beaucoup de
retraités s'inquiètent moins pour lui
que pour les jeunes générations